et là tu peux respirer ouais sexy ça
respire bien
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
flavien de air pur qui a une solution
qui était intéressante pour justement
aux fruits dans l'air pur peut nous
expliquer ce petit masque à quoi il sert
et comment ils marchent bien sûr alors
en fait c'est un masque donc pour ma
porte et qu'on amène son visage et qui
va permettre d'arrêter de respirer les
particules fines particules les plus
nocives pour l'organisme
non en fait on a une piste rations à
nanoparticules et c'est aussi très
confortable plutôt joli 100 % made in
france
donc voilà un peu tout ce qu'on a
développé ça fait un an et demi loin ni
google chinois la région s'est produit
d'accord en fait c'est une problématique
personnelle qu'on avait tous les deux on
aller au boulot en d'euros et on
respirait un air super trop lui et on a
appris c'était la troisième cause de
mortalité en france et on s'est dit et
ce qu'on peut pas trouver une solution
comment ils fonctionnent et
techniquement alors oui c'est
effectivement il ya plus de cinq couches
qui permettent de venir titré au fur et
à mesure les différentes particules
d'abord les plus grosses des filets plus
petit jusqu'à la nanoparticule mai et
ensuite on a aussi une couche de charbon
actif qui permet d'aller vraiment
filtrer les gaz et les odeurs pour un
comptoir c'est comme les masques à
retrouver pour
pendant la guerre c'est quand même un
peu plus joli
oui maintenant c'est aussi très léger et
très confortable en fait on respire très
très bien aussi
je veux essayer je t'en prie il faut
essayer alors comment ça marche alors
comment ça marche donc ça les deux
petites attaches le pelage sur le visage
moi je te la tâche aux plats faire une
petite attaque qui se mêleront l'adf ici
et qui serait derrière voilà c'est un
plat tu peut ajuster un peu au bas comme
ça c'est toi qui choisis voyais bien çà
et là tu peux respirer
ah ouais sexy ça respire bien c'est vrai
c'est un nom ça va ça on doit venir fait
on n'est pas mal et là encore tu es en
intérieur mais dès que tu vas être
l'extérieur la température de chômage à
10 15 degrés et la tête protégée en plus
c'est complètement imperméable du coup
même s'il pleut toujours au sec
un homme âgé derrière exactement aux
jeunes enlève bus pour qu'on puisse
m'entendre un petit peu mieux mais ok ça
marche donc là le petit masque à
l'intérieur à l'extérieur c'est ça ok je
suis tu peux le voir ici comme comme on
le voit sur la petite étiquette 100%
made in france fabrique est fabriqué en
france aussi pour être fabriqué en
france
en fait c'était vraiment ce qu'on
voulait faire on voulait faire un
produit qui va faire du bien
l'utilisateur mais qui va aussi faire du
bien à tout un écosystème
d'où le made in france et dernière chose
qui est très important a décidé de
reverser une partie de leurs bénéfices
les associations ya des projets qui
lutte contre la pollution de l'air alors
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens parce que tu
es un masque anti pollution mais nous ce
qu'on aimerait c'est dans cinq dix ans
qu'on a le plus besoin de porter
d'accord parce que c'est vachement
politique des grands guinée pense qu'il
ya une vraie carte à jouer on a une
vraie mission d'information car changer
les mentalités déjà prendre conscience
de la gravité la problématique s'y
attaquer pour que demain nos enfants
puissent respirer un air est parfait ça
serait bien
ça serait bien garder tout ce que je
trouvais d'oeil sur vos goûts fliers
ouais ça ne fait sympa c'est le côté
effectivement très pur très juvénile et
avec le côté un peu post apocalytique un
peu à la fallout comme je le disais tout
à l'heure avec le masque alors
effectivement c'est un masque qui rend
service qui va éviter d'être malade qui
est génial c'est à la fois géniale est à
la fois inquiétant parce qu'une vraie
prise de conscience des problématiques
de l'air et voir si c'est vraiment un
outil un outil est aujourd'hui
indispensable et je dis pas ça des start
up mais j'espère que l'on n'aura que
vostok ont pu résister sur autre chose
mais cette problématique là en tout cas
on y voit la gueule clamant leur des
sports d'espère au sida est ce que c'est
un produit qui est disponible dès
aujourd'hui on peut retrouver alors on
est encore en pré commande
donc les gens peuvent en tant que pré
commandez avant qu'il soit commercialisé
sur in vivo de retrouver ça sur notre
site internet et on commencera à livrer
les premières personnes fin du mois de
décembre et fin janvier pour les
prochains n'hésitez pas à l'exécuter
merci je vous invite vous laisser des
petits commentaires à me dire ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous vivez dans des villes où
vous avez des problèmes des pics de
pollution parce que cette solution
pourrait vous intéresser
vous marquez tout ça parce que c'est une
vraie problématique et puis c'est super
intéressant
il fit donc des idées qui sont géniales
tout cas super sympathique mans s'est
essayée sexy je vous ai donné sa jolie
pousse à vous abonner à laisser des
commentaires et on se retrouve très
bientôt pour parler d'autres entreprises
innovantes technologique française made
in france et d'autres vidéos étaient en
règle générale attend